The Google TV Remote app lets you control your TV from your Android phone or iPhone.
You can easily change channels, adjust the volume, and scroll through the home screen.
Your phone communicates with your TV via your Wi-Fi network,...
...instantly reacting to your commands.
The simple interface feels immediately familiar.
Searching for channels in the keyboard is as easy as texting your friends.
How many remote controls let you find your favorite shows using your own voice?
You can navigate to your favorite websites from the touchscreen...
...and bookmark your favorite content by pressing the star button.
Better yet, is the ability to share entertainment from your 3-inch screen to your big screen.
Perhaps the best part of all is that everyone in the room can use their own remote app at the same time.
Look for the Google TV app at Android Market and in the iPhone App Store.
Learn more at google.com/tv